the Greek Defense Minister panos
kammenos is paying a short visit to a
refugee camp on the outskirts of Athens
the camp was opened on Tuesday just in
time to meet the EU deadline we are
obliged to do our best to have all the
Welcome Center here but also our best to
stop this flow the stream of migrants
has become a serious problem for Greece
Athens used to be a transit stop but now
many are stuck in the city because they
are no longer permitted to cross the
border in the north here in this small
container village those who are not
allowed to continue their journey are
stranded africans Pakistanis Iranians
and Palestinians the people here in this
Campbell literally going nowhere most of
them have the permission to stay in
Greece for six months then they become
illegal few of the migrants expected to
be stuck in Greece many were taken by
surprise at the border to Macedonia stop
thinking I had returned back to at them
and then I think for collective
information for staying here in Greece
when I collect all information for the
situation here I will get this side of
me and stay here
but if those asylum claims are rejected
it won't be easy to deport the migrants
this is very difficult for the city it's
also difficult to send them back because
many countries do not accept them
so here again we need European
solidarity and most of all because of
the situation of economic crisis they
cannot even find work in this in this
country and in this city so it's even
worse than in the past
seeking asylum in crisis stricken Greece
for many migrants the prospects of
success are dim some haven't given up
hope of continuing their journey I'm
just trying to move on even borders are
closed or open I don't I don't care
because my life is very much much more
important than a border ok and I'm
deciding caring for my life not for
borders within 15 minutes panos kammenos
has finished his inspection of the camp
if the route to the rest of the EU
remains closed these visits are likely
to become a regular fixture on his
schedule